la mandinga es madre de valentín de 5
años de edad no está dispuesta a acatar
el llamado del gobierno ecuatoriano para
vacunar a su hijo contra el commit 19 su
postura radical anti vacunas proviene de
que pone en duda la temporalidad con la
que fueron desarrolladas y también la
desconfianza en el sistema de salud
ecuatoriano
nos parece que no tenemos
suficientemente distancia para ver qué
ocurriría con esta vacuna al grupo de
los niños y de las niñas sobre todo que
sabemos que no son un grupo digamos de
los más vulnerables a este virus
entonces nuestro caso
calculando un poquito vemos que hay como
más riesgo de vacunar a nuestros hijos
que de no vacunar los
el pediatra fernando aguinaga difiere de
la negativa de amante de no permitir la
inoculación de su hijo e insiste que la
vacuna no causará un daño letal a los
infantes muchas madres se lo piensan si
nosotros hablamos del cob y te vamos a
decir la mayoría no es una enfermedad
grave entonces yo creo que cuando la
mayoría madres reflexiona sobre este
tema mucho va a cambiar de opinión y
ojalá logremos es transformación masiva
la haría comer lucrecia nunca le ha
puesto ninguna vacuna a su hijo lautaro
de 9 años no es partidaria de las
inoculaciones sin embargo decidió
permitir que le apliquen la del 19 para
protegerlo porque su trabajo lo pone un
estado de vulnerabilidad ante el
contagio bueno yo tengo un local atiendo
personas
bueno personas variadas que no sé de
dónde provienen y cuál es su nivel de
protección ante el hobbit amante y
lucrecia con opiniones similares tomaron
decisiones opuestas para resguardar la
salud de sus hijos estas determinaciones
de muchas madres y su gran en la meta de
ecuador de alcanzar la inmunidad de
rebaño antes del fin de año